Vsauce Kevin here when KGB chairman Yuri
and drop-off was conducting a job
interview the man said let me tell you
about myself and drop off stopped him
and asked what makes you think that you
know more about you than we do that's
really creepy and also probably true
data collected by a self-reporting
compared to outside observation tends
not to be the same you'd think that the
most reliable way to get crime data is
to just ask the people involved both the
victims and the criminals going straight
to the source makes the most sense right
wrong because not only can we not trust
you you can't trust you
analyzing crimes criminals and victims
is Rife with problems it's a running
theme in my videos the worst math ever
used in court shows how probability can
be twisted and misapplied to be flat out
wrong and the Sally Clark video showed
how that can ruin lives if you think
eyewitness testimony is bulletproof ask
Jennifer Thompson and Ronald cotton and
if reducing crimes to objective data
seems Smart check out the Mad Lib that
is the U.S federal sentencing guidelines
or the data-driven monster called
compstat if if getting reliable
information from the criminal justice
system is too complex
why not make it as simple as possible by
collecting data directly from the people
involved in the crimes let's find out
even in the 1940s and 1950s researchers
knew systems were biased and highly
variable so they wanted to bypass the
bias by gathering data from primary
sources that way there's nothing getting
in the way of the truth except us
some of the problems with self-reporting
are obvious you need to ask people the
right questions bad questions bad
responses and you need to ask the right
people too great questions to the wrong
people just aren't useful at all I don't
know what it's like to go into space ask
an astronaut they would know especially
the ones that have been into space But
even a really straightforward and
objective question like measuring the
average height and weight of the
population can be a total mess we're
just dealing with numbers right this
should be simple let's ruin this in
three ways one doctors and nurses
measuring during Hospital appointments
this is professional data collection the
opposite of self-reporting two tracking
the average sizes of clothes purchased
over time this one's part professional
and part self-reporting three just
asking people so self-reporting Hospital
measurements are going to be accurate
but the sample is not likely to be
representative of the broader population
by default acutely sick and chronically
ill people are over represented the
result is a great measurement of an
atypical population so bad data Trends
and styles affect the size of clothing
people buy are the 186.9 million dollars
worth of jinko jeans sold in 1998 an
accurate measure of weight that year
Well puffy pants still have the same
waist and inseam right maybe take a look
at this chart detailing how size 8 is
actually 10 completely different
measurements depending on the retailer
vanity sizing ruins the data and the
larger people buy more or fewer clothes
than smaller people to skew the data set
and which stores should we even track
Brooks Brothers Tommy Bahama Ross Dress
for Less who knows bad data okay so
let's just ask people a 2009 study
showed that men over report their height
by about half an inch and women under
report their weight by an average of
three pounds it doesn't mean anyone is
lying they probably really believe
they're giving accurate information the
problem is that it's wrong so again bad
data is this all hopeless
yeah
yeah it's probably hopeless in 1964 a
photographer asked if she could shoot
Andy warhol's Marilyn Monroe paintings
he thought she meant photos but she
pulled out a pistol and fired a shot
through Marilyn's forehead it took four
minutes for shot Sage blue Maryland to
sell for 195 million dollars which
happened as nine trillion dollars was
wiped from the stock market and
inflation ran rampant Morgan Stanley
reports that the average fine art piece
is selling for 26 percent more at
auction compared to last year because
art has some unique qualities as an
investment you can buy shares in works
from great artists from Banksy to
Picasso with Masterworks they have over
half a million members because they've
gotten results like a sale in October
that netted a 21.5 return for its
investors as a result demand for
Masterworks is so high that there's a
wait list but you can skip it by
clicking the link in the description for
Priority Access and do every bit of
research you can all Investments carry
risk so be smart about it go to
masterworks.org vsauce2 and thanks to
Masterworks for sponsoring this video
James short and Ivan Nye sensed they
were getting misleading and incomplete
crime data in the 1950s and they were
they recognized that criminals can
manipulate to sway the tone of
interviews so they threw in questions to
expose over or under reporting of
delinquency like questions about whether
criminals had ever disobeyed their
parents or ever lied unrealistic answers
like claiming you've never once lied to
your parents presented an image of
manipulative over Conformity so those
respondents were excluded so if you know
data is routinely unreliable at least
you can filter out the very worst of it
the thing is most people do try hard to
be accurate but their own world view and
the limits of language can dramatically
skew the results let's use some of short
and nice real self-reporting questions
to generate some bad data have you ever
had a fist fight with one person
well what does that mean exactly does
horsing around with a sibling that gets
out of hand constitute a fist fight are
we talking competitive combat in akumate
or instigating or defending yourself in
a violent altercation those are all
pretty different fist fights have you
ever drank wine beer or liquor in your
own home
does that mean stealing your dad's
bottle of Pappy Van Winkle and guzzling
it in your bedroom or your mom giving
you one single sip of giggle juice on
New Year's Eve I don't know have you
ever driven too fast or recklessly to me
15 miles over the speed limit is too
fast to my grandma two miles over the
speed limit is a Death Race individual
judgment matters and we can't guarantee
that over and under interpretations will
cancel each other out to give us an
accurate picture probably the most
obvious problem with self-reporting is
that people lie especially as the
behavior to which they'd be admitting
even anonymously becomes more serious
you're more likely to admit to swiping a
sip of wine than overtaking an
international drug trafficking Syndicate
but occasionally self-reporting gives us
a nugget of extra extremely valuable
truth in 1978 the Rand Corporation
conducted surveys of inmates in
California penitentiaries to assess
their levels of criminal Behavior prior
to their incarceration inmates were
asked how many times per year they
committed each of the following crimes
and they got a median value burglary
robbery assault theft forgery and credit
card fraud fraud and all crimes except
drug dealing we'll say that someone at
the 50th percentile of crime frequency
for each of these offenses represents
the average criminal but what about the
criminals at the 90th percentile the
very worst ones burglary 232 robbery 87
assault 13 theft 425 forgery and credit
card fraud 206 fraud 258 all crimes
accept drug dealing 605
five
six hundred five
eight thefts a year is fewer than one a
month
425 is more than one a day the
differences here range from about five
times more crime like assault to 50
times more on thefts and fraud even if
the median inmate underreported his
crimes and the top 10 percent worst
criminals over reported because they
were bragging the data reveals a
substantial Gap we didn't know existed
we wouldn't need the exact numbers to
understand that the criminal class is
highly varied and that most criminals
haven't dedicated their entire life to
Crime but a portion absolutely
quantifiably have the good news is that
informs our approach to both punishment
and Rehabilitation the bad news is it
doesn't tell us the truth
we don't know exactly what the inmates
considered to be crimes whether they
were honest or whether they even
remembered correctly and it doesn't
answer the question about how we can
make sure criminals don't reoffend or
whether there are people we truly will
never be able to help
but it does tell us something and it's
up to us to use that information in
conjunction with everything else that
we've measured and collected
sometimes that is helpful
sometimes we have to admit
it's not
the strange thing is we know we can't
trust what people say
but if we never ask
we'll never know
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]